y la lactancia materna es una manera de
alimentar a su bebé con leche materna de
su propio cuerpo la leche materna se
produce en las glándulas mamarias a
partir de ahí se desplazan a través de
conductos mamarios a las aberturas en
los pezones
cuando el bebé succiona sus mamas su
cuerpo libera las hormonas prolactina y
oxitocina
y la prolactina controla la producción
de leche
y la oxitocina controla la liberación o
bajada de la leche a través de los
conductos mamarios la lactancia materna
beneficia a su bebé de muchas maneras
por ejemplo proporciona un equilibrio
óptimo de nutrientes proporción
anticuerpos para ayudar al sistema
inmune del bebé reduce el riesgo de asma
alergias cólicos obesidad diarrea y
ciertas infecciones de oído y de los
pulmones del bebé proporciona nutrientes
fáciles de digerir y reduce el riesgo de
síndrome de muerte súbita del lactante
la lactancia materna también le
beneficia a usted de muchas maneras por
ejemplo le brinda una forma cómoda y
económica de alimentar a su bebé le
ayuda a perder el exceso de peso
corporal ayuda a la contracción del
útero después del parto y aumenta el
vínculo entre usted y su bebé
hay cuatro posiciones básicas para la
lactancia materna posición de cuna
posición recostado sobre un lado
posición de cuna con brazo opuesto
y posición tipo pelota de fútbol
y el bebé nace con el instinto de
voltearse hacia el pezón con la boca
abierta y succionar para activar este
instinto presione levemente el pezón
hacia abajo por debajo de la nariz del
bebé hasta los labios
cuando el bebé abra la boca coloque el
pezón contra el paladar de la boca y
hacer que el bebé hacia la mamá es
posible que le lleve un tiempo al bebé
aprender a colocar su boca alrededor del
pezón o prenderse del pecho cuando se
haya aprendido correctamente la boca de
su bebé cubrir al pezón y la mayor parte
de la areola el área oscura alrededor
del pezón los labios del bebé se
reflexionarán hacia afuera y la nariz
tocará su seno debería escuchar sonidos
de succión regulares y suaves junto con
la deglución deje que su bebé succión en
todo el tiempo que quiera muchos recién
nacidos se alimentan entre 8 y 12 veces
por día